in this video we'll be talking about prb
and its role in cell cycle regulation
and in context of
retinoblastoma so prb is a protein which
is tumor suppressor in nature that means
it would suppress uncontrolled growth or
cancer formation so how does it do it so
basically prb regulates several aspects
of the cell cycle it is encoded by the
rb1 gene so the MRNA of prb eventually
getting translated into to the prb
protein so first of all we have to
understand how prb regulates the cell
cycle it turns out there is a critical
point during the time of cell cycle
which is known as R point or restriction
point and at the Restriction point the
cell assess the internal and external
condition and determine Is it wise to
proceed in the cell cycle or should the
cell cycle be paused so that is why prb
is a critical player in the Restriction
point it would take that critical
decision whether to go forward or
whether to Halt so prb basically
regulates another important
transcription Factor known as e2f or El
or elongation Factor 2f so basically
this particular factor is really
important for SASE
progression now basically once prb
encapsulate this Factor the cell cycle
progression is PA
now in order for the cell cycle to move
forward prb should separate out from the
e2f once e2f is free from prb cell cycle
progression can be resumed so what is it
happening e2f basically binds to
specific region that produces the
cycline e and cycl e is required for
replication in in the S phas e2f bind to
the cycline E Gene and basically lead to
its transcription so cyclan e is
produced with the help of e2f now e2f
can only do its job when prb let it do
its job so when prb is bound with e2f it
cannot bind to the DNA but when the prb
is basically phosphorilated with the
help of cycl DN cdk46 then the hyper
phosphorilated variant of prb releases
is the e2f and now e2f can bind to the
DNA and allow the progression of the
cell cycle from G1 to
S so cyclan D and cdk4 is a key player
but let me remind you that cycl D cdk4
is also regulated by the growth factor
availability so growth factor signaling
lead to the production of cyclan D so
that is why when there is too much of
growth factor there would be cycling de
production and suppression of the prb
activity thereby cell cycle can progress
into the next stage that simply tells us
cell cycle is highly Co coordinated with
the nutrient availability and prb cyclan
D all work in that interface to regulate
the nutrient availability and the cell
cycle progression now there could be
problems in the rb1 gene there could be
mutations in the rb1 gene which lead to
retinoblastoma which is a aggressive
form of the cancer in the retina so you
can see the retina looks like this in uh
retinoblastoma situation so obviously
the mutant rb1 Gene is unable to produce
a functional prb protein so once the
protein is non-functional cellular
aspects are abrogated so let's say we
talk about three situations first of all
let's say there is a growth factor
present in the media so obviously cell
would be dividing right cell would get
the nutrient necessary nutrient to
divide so PRP would be hyper
phosphorilated at this situation e2f can
bind to the DNA cyclan e can be produced
cell cycle can move from G1 to S imagine
a situation when growth factor is absent
in this case e2f would be inhibited by
prb and prb would not be phosphorilated
so obviously cell cycle progression
would be halted and cycl E won't be
produced but imagine a situation where
there is no growth factor in the media
but prb is mutated even if prb should be
inhibiting E2 it cannot in inhibit e2f
because it is non-functional in that in
in that condition even if there is no
growth factor cell cycle progression
would happen cell would grow and divide
but there is no U appropriate situation
for growth so this kind of disregulation
of the cell cycle happens in the prb
mutation which often lead to cancer now
there is a famous hypothesis by Alfred
nudson who was actually an American
physician and genetics he had a
hypothesis called two- hit hypothesis so
he says most of the genes require two
mutations to cause a phenotypic change
the first heat involves the inheriting
of one mutation from the parents and the
second heat could be often acquired from
the environment so it's can be sporadic
so that is why sporadic events are most
more rare compared to the familial
events it turns out retinoblastoma is a
complicated cancer in the retina which
has two forms familial and sporadic now
he concluded that inherited retin
blastoma occurs at younger age than
sporadic one and in addition children
with inherited retinoblastoma are often
more likely to develop the tumor in both
the eyes suggesting already there is
some sort of thing which is wrong there
is some kind of predisposition is
already there this thought lead to the
understanding how prb regulates the cell
cycle so this was a critical thought and
inference made by him so basically PRP
is expressed by both both the locus in
the chromosome that would that each of
any of these Locus can produce a
functional prb now Imagine One Locus is
gone due to a mutation that means still
prb would be produced from the other
Locus some amount of prb would still be
there but imagine a situation that then
both these ales are
mutated then there would be no
production of the functional prb protein
none of the alil can produce functional
PRP so in that prb deficiency or prb
functional deficiency would lead to
retinoblastoma development so this talks
about the two heit both these alic
variants alic copies are hit
actually now this is extremely rare in
terms of probability right the chances
that both the AL are mutated would be
obviously lesser compared to one Al
mutated versus no Al mutated right so
that is why there is the familial
retinoblastoma is more likely to have an
early onset because we should ask the
question what is the likelihood that two
copies of the rb1 gene would be
non-functional if there is a familial
predisposition the likelihood that
second copy would be mutated first would
be very high compared to a sporadic one
where at the time of bir both the AL
were function two mutations has to be
acquired simultaneously and that takes
time so that is why most of the cases
sporadic forms of rum blastoma has a
later
onset so this kind of tells us what is
the two hit hypothesis so obviously
likelihood of getting uh cancer is more
high in case of familial uh familial
Reginal blastoma compared to a sporadic
one so in this video we learn how prb
regulate the cycle by modulating the
cycling e expression and holding the e2f
um captive and later on we looked at two
heat hypothesis which tells us two
mutations are required for most of the
genes to create some sort of phenotypic
outcome so I hope this video was used
useful if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up and uh you can support
our Channel using super thanks which is
a hardship icon in the right hand side
of the video you can pay via PTM PayPal
or UPI see you in next
video